our voicemail number is two one nine two
david p i got a very important voicemail
about a topic that we discuss on
occasion but i want to broach again
today take a listen to this voicemail
that came in yes hi david my name is
travis first time caller
i was calling because i was wondering i
wanted to get your thoughts on memes
such as equating indentured servitude
with full-blown slavery and what would
be the best way to combat the spread of
misinformation like this hopefully i'll
hear from you yeah this is an important
question there's the micro answer and
there's the macro answer at the macro
level if we don't actually get it
together with some serious media
literacy and critical thinking material
for students i think starting no later
than middle school but even earlier i
would be open to you were not going to
have a population that is properly
equipped to actually pick apart and try
to interpret media messages and if you
don't have that that is like at the base
level why so many people fall for fake
news and misinformation and
disinformation we know particularly in
conservative states states like texas
where they have very right-wing boards
of education they have proactively
gotten rid of teaching things like
critical thinking period and when you
get to college before you've ever had
real classes about how to think you are
not going to be in a really good
position to filter the misinformation
and disinformation that is out there so
that's number one at the micro level we
do need to think about how the
algorithms on social media are creating
these filter bubbles and echo chambers
and i am not saying the government needs
to tell facebook how their algorithm
should work that that's not what i'm
saying and i don't think that there
would be a strong legal basis for doing
that but the problem of these sort of
cell free
forcing beliefs and these closed circles
where because you visit Breitbart you
get shown particular memes on Facebook
and it's recommended that you go and you
look at Infowars and then Shapiro's
website and stefan molyneux and then
you're very far down the rabbit hole
that's a very micro right now problem so
the macro is that no matter whether
people are consuming misinformation in a
newspaper in magazines sold out of you
know a kiosk or on social media at the
macro level people need to be more
educated about critical thinking we need
media literacy classes it's so funny
when I was in high school media literacy
was thought of as like the slacker class
where you just hang out and watch the
news and watch TV and listen to the
radio and record monologues and stuff
like that if we actually had strong
media literacy nationwide in this
country from an early age we would be so
much better off and then we've got to
deal with the filter bubble issue
somehow and I don't know what the answer
is but I'm glad that this caller and
other people in our audience are
thinking about it we have a great bonus
show for you today we will talk about
Senator Lindsey Graham getting booed
while defending Brett Kavanaugh at a
public event it's it's pretty funny also
we talked a lot about do we have enough
fuel to get to Mars or do we have a the
right spacecraft or whatever the
radiation that is an undeniable reality
of how we would currently get to Mars
and the effect that that would have on
human health is a major issue that is
going to have to be solved if we are
actually going to go to Mars we're going
to talk about that on the bonus show and
also we have the midterm elections
coming up in four and a half weeks how
informed is the average voter about who
their representative even is all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show WWE a common com become a patron
both ways get you access I will see you
then